At conception, a sperm, carrying either
an X or Y chromosome, fuses with an egg,
which carries an X chromosome. In this process,
a single cell, called a zygote, is formed. The
combination of chromosomes inside the cell
decides if the baby will be a boy or a girl.
An X and a Y chromosome create a male.
And two X a female. Around 1 in 5000 of
us happen to get a different chromosome
combination. They are sometimes referred
to as intersex and are proof that something as
binary as male and female can be on a spectrum.
For simplicity, we will
compare typical men and women.
At Birth, children are typically identified
as boys or girls. Boys tend to be slightly
larger and heavier than girls. Their
heads are often a bit bigger too!
Within weeks, cultural norms start to reinforce
traditional gender roles. This makes
it difficult for scientists to know
what behavioral differences are biological
and which ones are socially constructed.
During Childhood, boys tend to be more physically
active, exhibiting greater interest in objects and
exploration. They also begin to have a better
understanding of three-dimensional space.
Girls are less active, take a higher
interest in people, and seem to form
a better understanding of them. They also
learn new languages faster. At just 16 months,
girls, on average, have a vocabulary of
95 words, more than 3 times that of boys.
During Puberty, kids become
teenagers. Their bodies change,
and the differences between boys
and girls become more obvious.
Around the ages of 8 to 13, girls start to
get taller, their body shape begins to change,
and hair grows in new places. This
continues into their mid-to-late
teens. Puberty also brings the start of
their menstrual periods. Technically,
they can now become pregnant,
give birth, and feed their baby.
They also have elevated levels of the
hormone estrogen, are highly social,
and tend to show more empathy. Physically
not as strong as their male counterparts,
they exhibit a greater capacity to endure pain
and can rival men in ultra-endurance runs.
Boys enter puberty a bit later, with
a growth spurt that peaks around age
14. They develop more muscle mass,
body hair, and a larger Adam’s apple,
which gives them a deeper voice that
can intimidate some and attract others.
Boys also produce more testosterone and develop a
higher aggression potential. They are now larger,
faster, significantly stronger, and
about 10x more likely to end up in jail.
Some teens now identify as a gender different
from the sex assigned to them at birth and
about 3-10% enter their reproductive
years with an interest in the same sex.
During their Reproductive Years,
and until their mid-thirties,
both sexes are typically very good at making
babies. But they face two very different risks.
Men can technically make a baby in minutes.
Women however have to invest many months into
pregnancy and give birth — with vast physical
and psychological consequences. This puts them
at a lot of risk if the relationship breaks
apart. However, they do have one advantage.
Once the newborn arrives, mothers can be certain
that the infant is theirs. A father that loves
and cares for a child risks finding out it
is not his. And depending on the culture,
1-10% do unknowingly raise another man's
child. So what’s mama’s baby, is papa’s maybe.
A woman's anxiety about becoming a mother
with no help supporting the family and a man's
fear of paternal fraud is said to create
very different concerns about cheating.
One theory hence suggests that men tend to worry
more about sexual infidelity. They want to make
sure they're raising the child they fathered.
Women typically get more jealous when they feel
emotionally betrayed. They worry that precious
family resources are shared with someone else.
In Mid Adulthood, men and women begin to
lose some of their ability to make babies.
If we study fertility by Age we see that
women’s fertility drops from their early
thirties and by their forties, chances of getting
pregnant naturally are slim. Around their fifties
they enter menopause and their periods stop. Men
remain reproductive much longer, but from age 35,
the chance of producing a faulty sperm cell
increases exponentially with each passing year.
As they reach Late Adulthood, women live longer.
Men die about 6 years younger, often of heart
failure. Perhaps because they don’t care as much
about their health and live a more risky life.
What do you think? How do sex differences
influence our society and how does society
influence them? And should we
create laws and regulations
to purposefully reduce the differences?
Share your thoughts and comments below!
If you like this video and want us to make more,
subscribe to our channel or support us on Patreon.